vos personnages masqués viendra chanter
et derrière ce personnage se cachera une
star internationale
est ce que c'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
geslin côté de moi une star
internationale à deux centimètres de moi
je ne sais pas qui c'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors au cas alors les bonnes valeurs
toujours parce qu'ils étaient assez bien
merci
un risque à moins qu'un gars qui a plus
bronzé que l'autre sur laquelle revient
et aucun doute très bien vous avez
tourné il ya longtemps mais chéri on va
encore parler b et moi j'étais très
content de voir j'avais dit que vous
étiez dedans donc les enquêteurs ont
proposé plusieurs noms nos potes bien
sûr c'est nos quatre potes en plus un
enquêteur bien sûr alors il ya eu que
des noms hyper connu jusqu'au moment du
riz ville où là bas m'a regardé qui veut
y aller ces jarres yari allez je vais
partir soyons fausses sur uncanny minaj
abete
shakira chacun tu vas quand j'ai vu la
ballerine j'ai pensé aussi à natalie
portman ce qu'elle avait fait ce film
sublime tout à fait même à lady gaga
lady gaga hockey
eva longoria blush pas sûr du tout pas
mal aussi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
une fouille au sénat
john de caisse des dépôts tél
[Applaudissements]
on
e
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une marque de boîtes de toit sur
la tête de ma mère diana c'est un truc
c'est toujours petit navire sopic et
mumbai tous nos petits pas pas de quoi
non méritée benjamin non non non non
elle est connue mais pas franchement
déjà son look ne connaissez pas arrêter
ce qui ne la connaissent yves quéré des
le pape l faut l'avoir vu il eu dans ses
lignes internationales et je dirais que
c'était drôle à la nive à la samare télé
voilà mais bon ben c'est pas à ccs
l'époque laissé complètement dramatique
parce que le pire c'est que c'est même
pas la plus populaire mais aussi le
canadel pas tout ça donc c'est ça qui
n'ont pas lu el doctor on l'a mis sur
twitter même on aime bien ce même le cas
vont regarder la série on sait même pas
comment elle s'appelle oui enfin c'était
un message et jean-michel s'est arrêté à
ça mais j'étais content parce que j'ai
fait des booking en boîte avec elle
non merci
[Applaudissements]
strasbourg avec celui-là plus long de la
boîte elle était là lui c'est énorme
c'est un vrai scoop ce n'est pas que ces
six mois déjà parce qu'on nous l'avait
dit avant mais trop moche rappelé jean
cdc qui l'a oublié mais cette fois la
guadeloupe et en belgique fait partout
je suis comme dans l'altérité dans la
série yamnaine qui est gérée d'une
grande marque des bijoux sur ce mondial
et puis elle elle fait des bouquets avec
jean michel a visé dans les musées c'est
dark forest d'une bière a fait des
booking avec une grande star d'hannah
une grande chanteuse internationale
elle est chanteuse dans un groupe folk
basque
[Applaudissements]
mais moi c'est bon à moi j'aime l'aplomb
c'est exceptionnel c'est toi patois
c'est drôle l'aplomb et excepté oui jean
bernabé comment tf1 peut tomber si bas
non un fiasco monumental
j'étais avec ma fille j'ai appelé dix
personnes a déçu ni moi ni ma fille ni
les 10 pc sur et qui sait cette personne
ou non mais c'est incroyable non mais
valérie vous pouvez pas défendre ça non
mais tout vote mon espoir et reese est
un naufrage monumental c'est un scandale
que tf1 annonce une star nationale pour
cet inconnu de troisième les honneurs
[Applaudissements]
rigaud la faute - oui cette émission est
une parodie
oui je suis inquiet grotesque et donc
tous ridicules et droit ça me fait rire
alors moi je regarde l'émission avec des
enfants et des cas quelqu'un une glisse
et qu'il est donc on regarde sur
wikipédia oui pour savoir qui c'est et
pardon la grande star internationale moi
je veux bien ça face 17 millions dus
mais en fait la plata les papas qui peut
voir ça c'est sur netflix est ce que
c'est le public de tf1
non mais j'en suis bien c'est pas
possible non plus sinon pas dans mon
corps c'est la grande star c'est un
homme effexor ben oui c'est vrai mais là
c'est celle à laquelle vainqueur
laquelle l'afrique
bah oui voilà préoccupant il publie pas
vu non mais voilà c'est une canne à
namêche un drone et steve donc c'est pas
grand public solesmois sa sortie c'est
un mélange de personnes encore oui oui
j'ai quelques stars nationales sur tf1
c'est pas mêlant danse et ben je me suis
trompé